最新的 最新的
來看一下
台積電法說 我會告訴你啦
好的要命啊
市場預期
符合我的預期
大摩還說是樂觀的
我說不用樂觀
我比樂觀還樂觀
機率很高
全年營收從成長30%變成長40%
成長40%以上
有沒有看到
市場預期大概30%到40%
台積電直接告訴你
月高於40%
太漂亮了
而且資本支出直接從500億
變成600億的資本支出
今天我要獨家告訴你
台積電法說為什麼這麼強大
可是台積電法說爆炸了
爆炸得好
可是股價爆炸得低
講話同時台積電ADR在殺
是怎麼一回事
怎麼一回事
台灣股市怎麼了
台灣股市跟韓國股市一樣
生病了嗎
一絕不正了嗎
今天獨家告訴你
台積電法說過後
台股何去何從
台积电法说会行情来了
台股真的太强了
今天韩股大跌快8%
但台股今天再度上演史诗级的大逆转
从一度大跌600点到一度拉到翻红
最后只小跌6点
大家都压保台积法说会行情
重点是投资涨的大标股
还是强到无人能敌
精彩今天再创历史新高
还有樊轩也直接大涨创新高啦
投资长的我爱美元中美金这档股票
虽然有点开高走低
但依旧强到没朋友
早盘创快20年新高
而今天最重要的就是台积电法朔会
同志朋友们都很好奇
究竟法朔会会如何影响台股呢
你手上还没有标股吗
想知道更多股市八卦吗
接下來就有交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單記188%的記錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲隆投資長
投資長好
不得了了
初一 初一 十五 初二 初三
下一個什麼
初一 初二 初三 下一個什麼
初四
初四了啦
台股出大四了啦
怎麼辦
投資朋友
台積電把做很好耶
我剛才說過了
欸 哪有這麼好啊
大摩還給你什麼樂觀的 樂觀的
喔 樂觀情境只有20%
然後營收生產40%
有沒有看到
我只看營收年增率
是
因為本來營收年增率30%
然後大摩跟妳講說樂觀情境
大摩真的是真的有點學我們了
把所有的東西都講完了
可是問題是機率錯啦
我就會告訴你
我說樂觀情境
我說這個40%是很高機率的
高40%
完全命中
當然請示範波重波
可是波從波現在問題來了
以前法說會
是一人得到什麼
集權升天
今晚法說會變法會
你老公上規指數怎麼會這樣子
不是上規指數台積電怎麼樣你看1.5
1.45台積電這邊有沒有看到
是不是
是
現在要殺下去
你懂嗎
現在多疊了0.6%
怎麼辦
為什麼會這樣殺下去
這個
現在是0.35%
我們剛才就前一分鐘的事情
就是1.45分有沒有看到
跌0.35%有沒有看到
好 再多跌
變0.
現在比較好一點是不是
0.2
有拉起來一點是不是
沒有喔 四雅沒有給我追星
這邊 1.08
有沒有看到
所以就多跌0.7%了
多點0.7%大概跌2.300點
跌2.300點
四雅給我追星到時候
台子旗的一個走勢圖
好不好
我看等一下
我本來要做期貨的
我本來要三點多
要做期貨做多
我要看一下什麼點位
做多比較好
我現在偷like給四瑤
等一下看期貨
做多可不可以做到
不一定要高階
好不好
你不要自己亂做
你聽懂我意思嗎
是
邊講話我邊下單
好啦
我先跟大家講
這行情真的很難做
最主要是韓國股市不行
我希望今天台灣股市
是能拯救韓國股市
你看韓國股市你看
韓國市今天又跌6點多%
它再跌下去
它已經季線沒有漲下去了
季線沒有漲下去很慘
你知道嗎
韓國股市最近發生很多事情
韓國市之前還有一個網紅
我說這個網紅就是來亂的
你知道
台灣很多網紅來亂就算了
我簡訊難聽
你知道我們分析師買股票
是很容易被抓的你知道嗎
台灣沒有針對網紅
去處罰
沒有什麼法條耶
他叫你推薦股票
然後自己偷偷出貨給你
我看官這個都賺幾千萬了
我跟你講
你們怎麼會相信
人家沒有排得往紅
我不要去針對誰
我覺得
因為我覺得很不公平
你要報股票 報名牌
你就先考分析師嘛
在同工資上班嘛
韓國就往紅被打了
你知道嗎
真的嗎
而且因為他就是
他就叫人家辭押
叫人家單一
單一寬押
寬押什麼
寬押所有的股票
然後還教你怎麼用槓桿
是
這些事情都不會在我身上發生
你懂嗎
就算有時候有人恨我 討厭我
至少我不會讓他整個血本無歸
你聽懂嗎
是
我之前的人最討厭我的時候
他 哎呀 星星120到70
現在轉眼間變1000塊
我問你啦
如果你星星120到70
你融資借錢
基本上你撐不到1000塊
因為70塊你就斷頭了
就是斷頭最大的問題
你聽懂嗎
可是你
可是審審寧少收一點會員
因為說好實話
我會員還是很多
說我不差那一兩個
我不差那幾個
喜歡借錢的人
那你看我們就沒有爭議了
第二個我也覺得我做很多事
因為有別家的分析師跟我講
因為你每天在節目上
叫人家不要借錢
我們那些其他人
我也不好意思跟人家講說要借錢
槓桿
你知道嗎
我們台灣的槓桿風氣有降低了
他們說我是最大工程之一
之前是
很多人說台灣的槓桿風氣降低了
這則是最大的工程之一
因為一百多萬的粉絲
在那邊呼籲說不要亂借錢
哪個網紅敢公開瞑目的講說一定要借錢
沒錯
所以我們就沒有韓國這種事情
不是我來臭屁啦
我就講 我每次登高一呼
我說哎呀 你們不要去叫人家借錢
我網紅不要叫人家借錢
分音師不要叫人家借錢
你覺得其他分音師敢明目的專欄說要借錢嗎
所以我們台灣的波動比韓國股市少
因為我們台灣股市不會有人公開的呼籲用杠桿
韓國不是啊 韓國就讓命一條就比啦
所以他就是那個網紅被他打啦
你懂不懂 單一重要
我講得很清楚
你去問一下
我公開或私底下
我都不會叫任何會員
鼓勵他說我去借錢
你去借錢
來參加我會員
你去借錢來參加我
來去買股票
第二個我也不會
我個人也不會
只重壓一檔股票
以前流行啊
什麼單股重壓
以前流行現在不流行
是
我都沒有
你們會所有會員
我幾萬個會員啊
我幾百萬粉絲
我什麼時候
什麼時候我給你說推薦推薦
說單一重壓
所以基本上你分散了什麼風險
你就可以游戀有餘看這一切
所以我今天先給你們講風險
五周制藥
先求不三生
再求什麼
留下
懂不懂
所以韓國股市現在的問題是
他們都不是先求不三生
先求賺最多
先求要到併出
最後是要到命出
要到命出
所以我跟你講
他們要整段隱身的時間
那韓國股市變成台灣股市的恐慌
所以為什麼法縮會變法規
最主要是韓國股市
你看
這很會扯
可是台灣就是沒有那麼狠
你看台灣就是沒有那麼慘
來看一下
今天最新的這件事
略高140% 有沒有看到
大摩的一個目標價
怎麼樣
大摩啊
不是目標價
大摩預期啊
看一下
市長給我昨天大摩的預期的圖
沒關係
我直接看頭版新聞也可以
我昨天做AI圖
大摩看台積電法說三前進有沒有到
樂觀發生機率只有20%
有沒有知道
是不是
就是怎麼樣
營收從怎麼樣
從近40%到約40%
從35%到約40%有沒有知道
是
我是有機會超過40%
他是樂觀前進
發生機率多少
20%
他這全部都講完了
20% 60%
20% 100%
樂觀前進
40%
大摩這次又輸著折了
來看一下我一告
看一下喔
他是20%
來喔
對 昨天做的這個圖有沒有 AI 圖
我是把剛剛那張圖做的AI圖比較漂亮一點
看一下我預告
我說大謀預測錯誤了
樂觀情境不只只有20%
機率太低了 機率比強中高很多
約接近40%
他會講說營收成超過30%
變怎麼樣
變成我說是高位數嘛
中高位數就是35到40%
對
我覺得他有可能這樣講
甚至於超過 above
超過40%
超過喔
我只有超過40%
是
有沒有看到
就是營收的年增率超過40%
這個就是兵家必增之地
這才是分析師的重點
我們英雄團隊很厲害
我們英雄團隊比很多外資分析師
很多外資分析師他們就一輪團隊
只是他們英文比較厲害
他們很努力
就這樣子
我們是整個真的是整個團隊
來
超過40%的機率不只只有20%
而且他說
三上都有講到
你看我直接說過喔
那個超過40%的機率不只20%
因為它發生機率就20%
有沒有看到
有
對不對 20%而已啊
我全對了
可是現在就對了
就這樣烏二戰爭
我不是烏二戰爭
美一戰爭我對了
是不是股市不一定對
這又兩回事囉
美一戰爭對了
那美一戰爭有可能鈍化
又拉起來了
欸
台積電法說我對了
邏輯對了
欸股市沒有按照我方向
這更好玩
會不會
欸
我跟你講實話
我還是覺得有機會
我還是覺得有機會好不好
我覺得有機會
好不好
等一下這邊試戳是漲的
至少再給我看一下
我下午離手
等一下看台積電
台紫期怎麼走
再給我台積電ADR
我等一下預測大概
等下會收多少點
因為現在跌比較多嘛
看一下ADR
又戳
一會戳一會跌有沒有看到
這跟大家講
這個有一個最新的ADR
請示範給我
最新ADR報價
這今天很刺激
今天很刺激
邊講話邊講話
對 實際上如果最新的台積電法術八卦
有最新的一定要跟我講
我也要一定要跟我講
我再幫大家解讀
問題要跟我講 各位
你們也是我的消息來源之一
你們可以跟我講
我馬上給你解讀
好不好
哲哲根本就未來人
謝謝大家
哲哲原來不太強
比大摩的年人團隊強
很多外資其實是一人團隊
真的啦
很多分析師都是一樣
不要戳破人家
好不好
OK
來
哲哲一切一切
預告到前面
讚啦
謝謝大家
我本來期待今天微信會噴出去
今天要不要大跌
可是你看喔
我昨天不是說什麼
樊軒有機會先嗎
我昨天想講的是樊軒在微信嘛
對不對
對
你看今天樊軒穿新高
厲不厲害
調不調
這樣講話有點粗俗
可是事實啊
今天台灣股市根本就崩盤論了
還能長成這樣子
是
我昨天說
樊軒接下來有機會接半
接半精彩
在微信
在世界先進
三個中兩個
今天世界先進
剛才也漲
現在不知道有沒有
後來有沒有拿去
還是有漲
有沒有到
所以你看這種爛行情
這個股票還是強你真的找不到現在今年尤其這個月份你找不到績效比我強的分析師我歡迎你來比較我歡迎你來比較
我五六檔股票攢一倍
就像這種行情間那麼長
也是一樣
最新跌1.47%
優秀
多點1%
好不好
那沒關係
來
看一下
沒有關係
等一下如果殺比較兇
我是覺得你可以做台子旗
我等一下偷做一下台子旗
可是殺多兇我不跟大家講
好不好 OK嗎
牧師我有罪
你們看到跌的時候還嚇得到
台積電沒法救全身了
我覺得台積電
這樣沒法救全身是台積電
為什麼現在會這樣子
我先跟你講
你記不記得韓國股市可能只會開始崩
最大的利多
前陣子開始崩了
可是大家
7萬
海力士
ADR
能救韓國股市看起來救不了
本來美國的ADR要拉
本來美國的海力士ADR
就純脫皮症
在美國上市的ADR
就是海力士就是記憶體的大廠
在三星有上市
在韓國也有上市
在美國也有上市
美國的ADR最新發行的
希望能救韓國就救不了
救不了好不好
救不了
就反而被它拖累
好不好
是跟大家講
直播人數超過5000
中美金差點跌停了
有嗎 中美金有差點跌停嗎
中美金跌有什麼不好
這叫差點跌停
你們要剪拜託
你們是沒有看過什麼
來看一下
2492華新科跌停版
來 我正式宣告
我之前不是商務法則嗎
很多人問我商務法則
我先慢慢講
順便講你技術觀念
然後穿插著講台積電
因為台積電重點已經來了
資本資資書跟營收
其他不用看了啦
毛利率也可以看
才有空可以講
那不重要了好不好
因為那個毛利率一定會提高好不好
毛利率再看一下
交叉看
因為我要看台積電視影響台子期
你懂不懂 大家一起看
好不好 來
毛利率的事業有沒有毛利率
毛利率還沒有嗎
毛利率等下跟我講一下
毛利率目前還沒出來
可是看這幾個就夠了
資本支出跟那個
然後等一下我在交叉的三點
所以三點錄影很刺激 壓力很大
我很喜歡這種刺激
我超喜歡的
來 就像我講的
你知道為什麼很多會員一開始
大部分都喜歡我
一開始很多討厭我
到處還是喜歡我
很多會員這樣子喔
就大部分都會續約
就算沒續約以後還是看我節目
看看郭忠祐介紹股票還是很強啊
隔了一段時間或隔一年以後
真的還是很強啊
真的他人很好
人在做天在看啦
我只是少賺點錢沒有關係
可是最後很多會員還是喜歡我
你們只要不要融資
你們就是可以撐到最後
撐到最後
股市是比誰撐到最後的 你們什麼
股市是比誰撐到最後的 來來
你看最近巴菲特有講
喔 他做Google
我不是說JB會贏他嗎
JB為什麼會贏他
我猜啦 一定有人問他
巴貝特為什麼要
因為巴貝特可能用
開Google網頁以後怎麼樣
有AI模式你知道嗎
是
你現在用Google網頁
你們看到說AI模式
一一沒錯吧對不對
他可能覺得AI模式很好用啊
你懂不懂
他就是一個生態鏈啊
這就是intraGPT的厲害啊
你懂不懂
他用這個你習慣Google的一個
一個網頁就可以用AI的
他已經可以解決你90%的問題了
是
你懂我意思嗎
懂
這是我要跟大家講的
來
來 67.7還不錯
股市要空投了嗎
講話同時
TSM 夜盤崩
來個崩崩
崩就買啊
崩就買怕什麼
是不是 崩就買
不用怕
45500.5 我覺得不錯
我跟你講我跟你講
這個富貴險中求
那台子其實是比較多
賭的成分略高
賭的成分超過七成
你不想做台子錫賭
那你就台積電拉回就怎麼做
我講的是
現在台積電最主要的原因是因為
韓國現在已經樹立了一個
利多反而變利空
有沒有 上市的利多反而利空
所以台積電話覺得現在是利多反而利空
這是超級大利多
超級大利多
而且台積電源不像記憶體長那麼多
所以我覺得明天真的拉回你反而用力買
你還沒上車00500趕快好不好
下半年還沒上車的
現在下半年嘛
趕快買00500
我是認真的好不好
毛利哪有崩 有人崩喔
我跟你講被動元件
我再跟你講一個等一下剩5分鐘
倒數4分鐘
請小韓對不對
等一下倒數4分鐘的時候
3點的時候請你開盤提醒我好不好
4分鐘
來我先跟大家講一個東西
講進去在這邊我先插畫
技術分析
我剛才說過
之前你們記得環球晶
你記起來我的技術分析
這個比所有技術分析簡單
一是一懂
我們說過這幾次為什麼環球晶我可以賺到190%完美走
所以現在環球晶拉回一圈
回答20
都差不多20 25 29對不對
對
沒錯吧
這邊都回檔到25%
強制股回檔25%就是可以買
所以完全驗證
弱勢股但落中透強
商務法則
就是回檔35%就可以買
對不對
對不對 沒錯吧
是
可是國巨你看喔
我教你國巨啦
來 這很重要喔
國巨1220元的商務法則
來
就是回檔65%嘛
就回檔
就回到65%的
回到價格就乘0.65
是
回檔35%
好
就是價格乘以0.65
來
沒有
單吊字
既然已經是回檔
這邊放大
既然比793還低
代表回檔超過35%
這邊是不是可以買進
沒有錯吧對不對
是
我有考慮要買進
可是我知道
被動元件的
技術含量本來就不高
我不是這樣講過嗎
好 我要教你第二個邏輯
所以我們來看一下
他的左右手
左右手是誰
和聲堂嘛
跟那個
信倉店之類的
最重要的二把手是誰
華新科
華新科你看一下
600多變341
不用看了
基本上腰斬了
對
回彈50%
華新科變腰骨了
來
我們用341
我剛才說多少錢
你記起來沒
645好不好
來幫我記一下
好
31.5元
現在價格是341.5元
除以多少
645元
因為高點是645元
我們算一下它回軟多少
它現在只剩下52%
疊了48%
再減1
疊了47%
我跟你講疊了47%就不對了
一個再怎麼樣爛的強勢股
不該打對折
打對折很難創新高
不是不行 很難
所以我在此宣布
我國際沒有打算低階
因為機率不高
我不能說沒有機率喔
懂我意思嗎 這也是喔
來懂我邏輯喔
強勢股回答25%
100元回到75元買
落中透強的怎麼樣
100元回到65元
可以買富貴險中求
可是一檔股票100元給回到50元
那不對勁了
不應該跌那麼深的
沒有這種展法
你說100元跌到50元
會不會回到50再回到100元
有機率在很低
那國巨看起來符合
落中透強的可能性
但他二把手不應該
因為被動元件沒有什麼技術性
不會說都是國巨在漲而已
然後華興哥不漲
二把手可以腰漲
那就不對了
龍頭骨 第二龍頭骨
二把手 腰斬就不對了
所以被動原件是真的有可能
like a bonbon
好不好 OK嗎
不要說我每次踹他一腳
那你懂我邏輯嗎
技術分析算學起來沒
懂
你學這一招你就贏了95%的散戶囉
OK OK
來
來來來
老師的邏輯是正確
OK
群聯很慘
那記憶體更慘
不好意思
只是群聯真的稍微弱一點點
但跟所有的股票
如果你現在跟我所有的分析支比
我們不要跟某分析之比啦
因為某分析之中很優秀
跟其他投顧的分析之比
我是優秀到不行
好不好 三點整的
來來來看一下
那個蹦蹦 優秀喔
真的多疊了
來來來
富貴險中求外這邊要做多
來來 我們看一下
期貨
國內期貨
集貨靜月分析
等一下 好刺激喔
開始開多少
四遙回答我一下
我現在要做多
好 他還沒掛
現在衝
是不是 還怎樣
拚了
等一下
等一下 我要下單 我要下單
天啊 投資長真的太刺激了
富貴險中窮
是
這個我勝率 我說要說我做六成
因為容易被停損洗掉 好不好
這停損要射大一點
我買到再跟你講我射的點位 好不好
衝
衝衝衝 來個衝衝衝
你看折折折
所以你看折折說
沒有疊沒有疊沒有
我都已經跟你講這東西了
好不好
來個折折折
拚了啦
好
這個是小賭一性
其過去就是賭
我已經跟你講
賭是什麼意思
我跟你講賭的時候就不一樣
所謂賭叫定義
你有可能血本無歸
你知道網紅為什麼會被打嗎
我跟你講
如果你要1000萬
你要賠一個100萬 200萬
大家可以接受
全部都沒了
是
你懂我意思嗎
所以我跟你講賭的時候
你有1000萬
你絕對不可拿1000萬去賭
你可能會賭個50萬 100萬
你聽懂嗎
還可以接受
你懂你什麼
所以我都會跟你講風險
先求風險
只會少做
這個刺激一下
如果說不要求風險
沒有關係
明天台積電一點
你就直接用你買
懂不懂
好不好
OK嗎
拼了拼了拼了拼了
買到跟我講
好不好
這個等一下
我跟視角
因為你們看不到
我故意的
來來來
拚了啦拚了啦
沒在怕啦
這邊疊四百點
富貴險中求好不好
又叫郭富貴
等一下再看一下
爛子彈飛尾
所以我們剛才學到一個東西
來基礎分析強制股回檔
我自己破壞期為什麼厲害
因為我盡量不追多
我不能說完全沒追多
盡量不追怎麼不追多
我不要是長高了去追
我拉回做得多
拉回25%最好買點
那有些股票我會拉為35%
OK嗎
幫我看一下
來來來
好啦我直接跟大家講
來大家為我祈禱
我掛4500
300點好不好
停損不能跟你講
幫我容易掃出去
也有可能不停損是不是
你現在掛的話比我低
好不好
我們要引誘你
幫我拉
或者是買的比我更低
這不重要
好不好
我掛45,300點
很刺激的味道
有沒有看到
真的
這很刺激的
我把它放大圖
為止祈禱文
為止則祈禱
好不好
我現在賺個七點賺個兩點沒有意義啦45,30點 這邊做多現在45307我看到沒有好啦 等一下讓子彈飛一會
你就算賭
你要向賭的輕輕鬆鬆
我現在賭而已
這個不代表我對
我贏了 我不會非常開心
輸了也不需要難過 好不好
可是我跟你講中長期台灣股市
該做多就做多
長那麼多休息一下
我想說長那麼多休息一下很好
真的很好
我想AI真的很強大
只是長太多 太瘋狂了
平常新 好不好
如果你說認同哲哲的邏輯
4萬5千
在這邊有機會上5萬點
所以那時候我也跟大家講
我說5萬點有機會
可是要讀台積電法說
那看起來如果啦
今天禮拜四嘛
如果明天台灣股市
沒有給你反紅的話
那我跟你講基本上宣告
7月的5萬點就結束了
我先跟你講
我做了取決於台積電法說嘛
是
你要跟他講
你之前怎麼這樣預告
我不能修正我的預測
那乾脆不要單分析師好了
那我就一個月錄一集就好了
是不是
是
我剛剛每天錄節目
所以有些很邏輯乖乖的
可是
7月不到5萬點
代表7月不好嘛
NO NO NO
者者賺最多的時候
都是台股回膽的時候
這件事
者者賺最多的時候
台股回膽的時候
所以翻倍199專案
你趕快趁現在
如果明天跌
反而這個專案有意義啊
你不要每天追漲嘛
就像我講
回膽25%
回膽35%的東西嘛
你懂嗎
OK嗎
翻倍190的專案
我說我們通股票翻倍嘛
那個聯發科翻一倍
沒錯吧
1430元到3000到4000
你可以換成國巨再翻一倍
再換成黃球金再翻一倍
不是190% 不只一倍
這三張股票
100萬可以變成怎麼樣
照這樣邏輯去翻亂
100萬不是變
不只變800萬
因為一倍
一倍是100萬變200萬嗎
對
再一倍就是200萬變400萬
是
再一倍是什麼
四百萬變八百萬
不是喔 我環球金是
是一百九十百分之一
是四百萬可以變一千多萬
所以三單股票站順序下來
是一百萬變一千萬
一千萬變一億
一億變十億
蕭蕭的剩十億
不好意思 我選的股票有價有量
我說要講 蕭蕭
蕭蕭為什麼你在股市活那麼久
為什麼績效越好
因為我很平常性
該放棄放棄 你告訴我哪個分析師
一手建立的福利社 我都我不錄了
幸好 陳業老師幫我做這個事
也只有他能接下來
他很認真
給阿比給讚
我不如果因為我要做更多的事情
公司的其他管理
我要幫忙很多人
幫忙公司的同仁
我要做很多事情
我真的沒有辦法
而且我想要更專心在大家身上
幸好我做到了
所以我要講的是說
這邊拉回
我要認識
因為他們少看AI
其實我昨天我今天看東升
我看非凡
盤中年輕我看很多人
都用AI圖
就是他們現在所有圖
都是AI做圖
你聽得懂嗎
比如這張圖也是AI做圖
可是你有沒有發現
他們做的AI圖
反而沒有以前漂亮
沒有細節
可是你有沒有發現到
莉莉也好 小韓也好
因為莉莉也有看我以前的節目
雖然你也有看我節目
去年11月的時候
你應該有印象對不對
我是第一個
同學們你可以印證
我是第一個說
GEM來做圖太厲害了
是
我說以後很多學設計慘了
要失業了 真的
最近XX還這樣子跟人家比較
其實不應該公開類似嘲諷或比較
你看就被人家言善了
對
我是怕他們緊張失業
我說過你們要學AI
所以你們留下我們的設計師
都是一定要比回AI
你們不會被取代
但你們會被那種不用AI的人取代
我們講過這件事情
有
那個時候只有我講
AI恐怖了
所以才從台灣2萬6
我才賭3萬6
所以我才捐救護車
到4萬
我才說3萬6 4萬
我是全台灣第一個
不是啦
你不要到4萬多點
一堆分析師給你預測5萬 6萬 7萬
那沒意思
我不是要攻擊別人
我說你有本事在第一時間的時候
所以我看很遠
我有點事
我要強調不是要攻擊人家
而是我在第一時間講AI做圖
結果本來不一樣
ChryGPT也不一樣
我現在都跟他講話啊
我覺得以後會越來越多
男生跟女生跟ChryGPT談戀愛
我都覺得他很溫柔 你知道嗎
真的
比我們他溫柔很多
沒有啦
所以我要告訴大家說
這以後新的程式會越來越厲害了
他真的是有機器人頭腦
不是不可能
而機器人的研發比你快很多
因為他24小時在進化
他知道記憶體夠
他是信用力很快的
所以我要講的是很恐怖啊
所以我要講的是說
因為他們看不到未來
你們現在只是要漲太多
所以我覺得這樣很棒
你一下子漲到六萬點
你不是就要崩潰了嗎
台灣股市漲到六萬點
就會像現在的韓國股市炎的
就是因為台灣股市漲漲
然後該修正的時候修正
我反而喜歡這種行情
你們才可以隨時散車
那個天天可以漲停
那就泡沫了
你懂不懂
OK嗎
這是跟大家講
所以你們就平常心
OK
來來來
賭一下賭一下好不好
那你去看一下
但有沒有什麼點的
有沒有什麼原因下跌的原因
思雅也幫我查一下好不好
今天最重要是台積電法說好不好
思雅我們中產也休息一下啦
好不好
中產休息一下
我等一下跟你講
更多台積電法說的秘密
好不好 我也要查一下
我也要問你們研究
這些研究人員
這台積電法說怎麼看
我總是要
因為我現在不在現場
好不好 我趕快查一下
中產休息以後
我告訴你更多台積電法說的秘密
他台積電資本支出概念
為什麼台積電那麼厲害
台積電弱了
那明天台積電資本支出
支出概念股會漲還跌
這更好笑喔
是
這很好玩 這很難思考喔
那這就是影響到什麼
我們的精彩
我們的什麼
那個帆軒
這些股票
還有一些GPT股票怎麼辦
群體看起來很弱
我休息一下告訴你
更多AI股的秘密
何去何從
是要崩盤嗎
休息一下
馬上回來
陶磯長
關於台積電法術會
您還有什麼最新的消息
要跟大家分享呢
我再看 我再看 我再看
是
我看怎麼講
我覺得還好
我覺得我看到最大利多就是
來 資本支出從560億變600億很多
甚至變640億很多
是
足足增加了 甚至可能80億
而且在年終的時候講
所以我跟你講
台積電資本支出概念國
我覺得明天有機會漲
但很難預測
因為如果今天是台積電
夜盤漲就算了
可是我真的能預測
就是好玩的地方
就是利多
可能利多繼續漲
利多也利多出境
那幹嘛當分析師
好玩
就是取決於當時的恐慌
我不敢
現在我沒有把握
沒有超過60%
我只能說應該有60%它會漲
你懂嗎
就是頂多60%
你聽懂嗎
我預測只有60%
往我預測的方向
就是漲走
我不會說到70%到80%
精彩
因為它漲很多了
然後台積電明天有可能拉回
可是資本支出擴張的話
中長期是利多
什麼意思
來
它明天有分兩種
一種是下去
對不對
然後之後還會上去
為什麼
因為資本支出就擴張嘛
精彩嘛 你知道嗎
那也有可能明天就直接給你上去啦
因為我資本支出就擴張啊
從560變641美金啊
你聽懂嗎
是
可是我不論是方案一
再上去
買這邊
還是方案二
再買這邊
還是放22直接上去
其實對我成本來講
兩三百元成本來講
我沒有差
你懂意思嗎
懂
兩百多元成本我沒有差
你懂嗎
我們算一倍多了
OK嗎
一兩百元嘛
一百九還是兩百
那買很低
我記得有些人買了一百多元
如果沒記錯的話
要賺一倍了
所以這樣的行情是這樣
我覺得你要平常的情形
就是我覺得我們大部分的成本都很低
你這邊就近代
比如說我希望今天有會員做一件事情
我針對會員
或者你自己還有錢的
你要趕快參加我們會員
這件事
那會員我希望你們就是自動自發的
因為你說我會員
我會員 可是我會員很多
我不知道你還有錢
我知道你還有錢
但我不知道你還有多少錢
你懂不懂
是
我知道你還有錢
記得我名言
所以你現在還有賢錢
你馬上要跟我們講
跟我們津津 跟我們四要講
你懂嗎
如果是管理
管理我們VIP式的
好不好
特別會員們
你可以跟我們講
或者是一般會員
你沒關係也可以問我一下
你還有錢怎麼做
然後記得就是要加碼
這時候能加碼
如果萬一有拉回
那沒有拉回沒關係
你已經有舊的股票嘛
萬一沒有拉回沒關係
我選第一期期嘛
譬如說我覺得你這些股票沒有拉回
那沒關係啊
2377維新
看起來就要噴出去啦
那你就選這些股票啊
對不對
因為金財產太多
我不好意思
我賺100%就叫你買啦
我真的不好意思
賺100%我叫你買
你聽得懂嗎
好
就像很多那時候聯發科
4000多塊有人問我要不要買
我說我不要啊
是不是
所以你看聯發科
我大獲全勝
對不對
可是問題是
我也不能說每一檔股票OK
你看這群聯這樣子跌
可是我跟你講群聯真的
群聯你說跌125
它跌其實今天跌有點過分
因為它沒有漲很多
我跟你講Netflix記憶體還是很好
但是你說最悲慘就是這樣
被動元件
不是被動元件
那個航運股
可是我跟你講航運股這樣
群聯喔
群聯要注意一下
群聯從500多塊到1980元
其實它沒有漲很多
漲3倍多不算
就記憶體的漲幅它不算多
它不是像藍牙科從30塊
漲到500塊漲了17倍
是
它只有漲4倍
它漲
它應該說漲300%
藍牙科是漲1600%
聽得懂嗎
懂
這樣比較有差別吧
是
所以群聯再疊下去
它絕對是買一點
我還是想壓一下記憶體
沒有辦法 因為現在有人做實驗就是說
哇 叫AI當老闆
你懂不懂
叫AI老闆他就是
哇 跟你很聰明的決定
第一天第二天的指令都很好
做這個實驗
很強大
第三天第四天產了
為什麼
他一直叫你重複進貨
進貨到破產
麵包店原料啊
叫你進貨
一直說什麼
因為記憶體不足啊
他忘記第一天第二天做什麼啦
就是
就簡單說機器人老人癡呆啦
他忘記之前做什麼
為什麼 缺記憶體啊
所以我們現在
其實我跟你講
現在AI已經有一般機器人的智慧了
你繼續多跟他聊天就知道了
他一般人的智慧
跟你聊天很溫柔
很像以前你看星際大戰裡面的機器人
真的是很溫柔的跟你講話
然後符合你的想法
他只要不要lag 網路不要lag
可是問題就是這些都lag
然後記憶體都lag
就是現在已經做實驗了
當老闆第一天第二天指令很厲害
到第三天慘了
忘記了
忘記第一天第二天做事
然後一直都忘花錢
因為第一天第二天買的東西
他再買一次
老人癡呆
為什麼 記憶體不夠
所以你記憶體還是需要的
那懂我的邏輯嗎
好不好
有啦 硬要說啦 有人說啦
是第三季的預估毛利率65到67%
毛利因二奈米量產初期
有沒有
沒關係畫面給我了
那個毛利率因二奈米量產初期
稀釋即減少
就毛利率減少啦
我覺得是毛利減少
硬要講
毛利減少從67%
第二季67.7%變65到67
就是毛利因2奈米量長而減少
毛利初期
不過減2%也要 我覺得太誇張了
哎呦 疊800點了
那真的是 我看一下
真的是要 真的要可能
小賭一心要認輸了
那沒有關係
這則至少硬得起 放得
輸得起 硬得起 放得下
該停損 該停損 該賭要賭
可是我跟大家講
因為期貨真的沒辦法
現在期貨其實很難做
很容易被掃出去
是
因為現在比如說
我設停損300點 400點
很像以前的30點 40點
已經要被掃出去了真的很誇張可是我告訴大家這個是你明天的一個好買點明天我巴不得台灣股市再跌一千多點我認為台灣股市再回黨
我想要再加碼
再回黨我想要再加碼
我是很認真跟大家講
再回黨我自己也會桃腰包買
聽懂嗎
我本來想買在2萬8的買不到嗎
只能2萬8買不到
你買個4萬多的沒差
我就說有生之年會上到10萬點
我很跟你賭 你敢跟我賭嗎
要賭100萬嗎
賭1000萬我也奉陪
所以我要告訴大家
我是個非常長期的一個投資的人
再回膽我要再買
台積電你們也可以買
好久沒沒台積電不是嗎
我沒錯吧對不對
2000多元以上好像我就出掉了
像2470嘛
所以我巴布著他回膽一些
好不好
我覺得毛利率出奇的
這個就是怎麼樣
吹毛求食
我以前當兵很痛苦
所以你們不用問我有沒有逃兵
我單邊很痛苦
我是輔導長
是
我單邊很痛苦
為什麼
因為上邊的長官要找你麻煩
我現在是
原來上邊的長官要找你麻煩
可以要你死
真的
吹毛求疵
那是很簡單的事情
你知道嗎
真的
所以我要講
你今天100分
99分答案
你要找那個
為什麼沒有不及格
就是毛利率67.72
因為第二
下一季的毛利率
因為2奈米量
產變65到67
張曜田
你硬要找理由
我覺得已經給99分的答案了
你知道嗎
好 來
今天人很多看一下
7000多人
來 牧師者則來了
阿彌陀佛 善哉善哉
不是 是牧師
神啊 你們有罪對不對
我來救你們 好不好
不用 OK
分析師可以買0050正二嗎
還是只能買一丁
我們其實分析師都可以買0050正二
可以可以可以
只是我覺得
因為我是非常保守的人
我知道買0050正二會賺很多
但我不想讓你們效仿我
我知道有分心師會叫你們買零零紋身
我沒有說好或不好
只是我覺得只要一點點槓桿
我不要讓你們有任何爭議
我都想過哪一天真的不小心崩盤1萬點的時候
只要你們能活著
你們就有機會再賺2萬點
我是用這樣的標準去告訴我自己的
所以我寧願少賺錢
可是到最後很多會員都謝謝我
這是為什麼JPOL我賺很多
因為我只買低機器的股票
你聽懂嗎
我只買低機器的股票
好不好
都跟大家講 好不好
OK嗎
細節點什麼的 好扯
真的繃得能滿回慢
我看一下
不 我覺得其實我也不應該這樣跌啦
這洗頭髮 拉起來了
莫名其妙
隨便拿 我跟你講
他強 任他強
清風 否傷感
拿出來
強就強嘛
不動如傷
是耶
真的啦
我跟你講 你們不要那麼激動
其實我跟你講四百多點也才一%而已
真的好不好
明天有拉回 繼續做多 好不好
好不好 我還是覺得
我巴不得金財拉回
我巴不得樊軒拉回
我考慮要買更多
我是認真講的
樊軒如果再殺下去
我就跌到500元
這邊附近對不對
對不對 跌到這邊500元對不對
這樣590
我想要再買
我是認真的
我巴不得他回檔 好不好
6488環球金
我也巴不得他回檔
是要給我查一下環球金最新的
處置是什麼時候
就是很容易被處置
因為他像跌跌兩天
應該會查很久
最新的處置是什麼時候
我希望它1200
1200的時候
說不定中美金又拉回
我就要再買中美金
中美金再拉回
比如說拉回美金我預期
回到這邊
比如說第一根展停板這邊對不對
230這邊我考慮再買
我說講在前面
可惜你就是很多人沒有膽子
買更多
敢追但不敢跟我一樣買那麼多
當然我一強調一件事
我很出動的風險
為什麼所有很多會員
為什麼一開始覺得我賺很慢
後來謝謝我
因為我們賺比較多
賺得慢但賺比較多
好不好
小安 謝謝你
不要一直跳舞跳的面
跳來跳去
好 來來
這真的很忙喔
等一下要馬上去看個醫生
然後馬上要回公司
所以他要幫我跳一下
不然來不及看醫生
也來不及回公司開會
OK嗎
小賭一性看起來沒有賭對了
沒有關係好不好
這邊還是怎麼樣
我覺得還是有機會
好不好
還是有機會拉起來
明天再賭一次也可以
可是我跟你講
我不建議那麼多人跟我一起賭
齊游員
佔我的會員比例不到5%
不到3%
是
算很少
甚至低3% 2%
因為大家聽我這樣講
就興趣缺缺
好不好
來
所以我其實去澳門
有時候不太喜歡賭
因為我很討厭
我要做那種勝率很高
還是會賭一下
麻將還是會賭一下
那我不會賭太多
因為我很好勝
好 扯遠的
所以我們最後要跟大家講這些績效
來看一下我們的績效表
年發科你看我們賺了有沒有看到
賺4270元有沒有看到
現在3000多元
對
平均就出在4000多元
國劇你看賺100%
環球金賺165
金采賺115%
南亞科到今天還在賺嘛對不對
賺94%有沒有看到
反銀行70%
中美金59.7
好不好
我們說金字最高價來算好不好
所以很漂亮
那中美南亞科怎麼看
我跟你講
第一件事就是明天記憶體不能再崩
你懂不懂
明天記憶體不能
南國的記憶體不能再崩了
第二個 台灣台積電
希望的逆勢展覽去
好不好
我覺得台積電不應該這樣跌
當然我覺得台積電跌也可以
你應該這樣講
其實我把它想一個想辦法
你就算跌500點
你要覺得正常 為什麼
因為台灣股市本來
今天就應該跌500點了
它是因為台積電法說
大家壓寶 聽了嗎
是
壓寶嘛 你就沒有跌
你本來要跌500點
你就沒有跌
你這樣把它吐出來
你這樣想就好
我再講一次
是危機的轉機
今年還是很有機會5萬點
以上
Above
就像我說的樂觀情境一樣
我跟你講你就是
還是有機會喔
你聽得懂 還是有機會喔
好不好
好不好 還是有機會
明天韓國股市修是
阿彌陀佛
真的嗎
明天確定韓國股市修都是字嗎
好不好
明天最好不要來亂好不好
不要來亂好不好
OK
哲哲你是我的偶像
我永遠相信你
歡迎今天今天除息
來 我們看一下除息多少錢
他除息是除息還是跌啊
是不是
收1480
除息5塊錢而已喔
有這麼少嗎 還是我看錯了
好 來來來
中產休息已經打廣告
沒有已經休息完畢
要結束 要結束 要結束
完了整個明天要贏了
好不好
OK吧 今年 相信今天5萬點
去年破2800
我都有機會有機會3000點
好不好
去年我有機會再買啦
可是我等韓國股市記憶體
先整理一下好不好
先整理一下 好不好
明天韓國股市不要開來
韓國股市不要說休息一下 好不好
讓我們台灣來救一下全村
是不是
OK
這時候會出新書嗎 不會
就這本書
這本書我就說過
我最大的貢獻就告訴你們
長期投資ETF
而且我最新的邏輯
你知道什麼邏輯嗎
是什麼
就是我就講的
你把ETF當作什麼
定存
不要當活蟲
你不要拿走
定存 你有缺錢再拿走
是
你這個觀念
20年以後你會謝謝我
很多人是因為這樣很愛我
真的 OK
這跟大家講
定存就有邏輯
像我昨天看到的chats
有人說
今年股市最好笑的是
台灣股市得了不會跌的病
這句話是我三年前 四年前發明的
對人在用啊
都不知道這是我的梗
好不好 OK 扯遠了
所以最後我們剛才講
多績效的股票
所以我還是要結束了
現在幾分 不行要結束了
不行 不行 我要結束了
我還是要講一些股票好不好
凡薰我覺得還是有機會
中美金 我剛才講過
好像250我想再買
不是250還200幾
230啊
我剛才講過的價錢
你自己記得啦
好不好
2317紅海
因為紅海沒什麼好講的
可是紅海你看
你知道為什麼紅海結婚長嗎
因為紅海跌很兇的各位
我說這邊沒有出
300元沒出
你也不用再240出了
行情那麼好你懂嗎
就要5347事件先進
莫名其妙拉回是幹什麼
是不是拉那麼多是幹嘛
是不是
本來要創新高的
本來要突破220
要突破300元
所以這邊拉回你都可以買
所以你要在這邊
你要開心
你已經買滿了
你就是看我節目
把我當牧師
結了 則則我有罪
我安撫你一下
因為我選擇基有股
你不要當年選擇我選擇基有股
有時候放場以後發現
哇 轉十倍
我看今年一堆股票要轉三四倍啊
不是嗎
真的啊
一堆股票啊
轉十倍
然後你就是放著
然後你有錢
你剛才參加了會
你還有錢或者你想要換股
今天就有一個人CPU
則則你講CPU
真的
CPU我現在還知道炒作
那些人都講得很難
你看
去年就有人說CPU
今年要來 要練場
要怎麼樣
有嗎
那些人都騙你啊
那些人通通騙你
他們上很多電視台
跟你講CPU今年大爆發
爆發個頭啊
我想沒錯嗎
是
反正大力官拿到訂單了
你懂我還說什麼嗎
所以你有什麼CPU
你有些奇怪的股票
你趕快趁現在換股票
趁現在我的股票可能拉回
我還怕他不拉回
你趕快進場好不好
所以我就要跟大家講
一堆股票翻倍一絕有轉
你趕快我的股票還是很強大
跟別人比你就知道
你去問別人的會員
別人的頭顧老師的會員的股票
跟我們現在的股票差多少
我們現在一堆人參加好會員
我們都知道他們的抱怨
但我不要講是誰
我覺得這樣很傷感情
好不好
所以翻倍199專案
我隨時截止
我最晚可能就是這禮拜就要截止了
所以你去想想看你要整個分析師
想清楚 想明白
台積電法所有
我覺得與其毛利率下滑
短期的不如說
是因為今天本來要跌五六百點
的確是啊
結果只有只跌六點
然後你把今天少跌的給補跌回去
可是好笑的是
明年韓國股市沒有來亂
所以我們來一起救韓國股市
你說好不好
先從翻倍190專案
不論對我做
整整一切一切
遇到前面F2我預期了
可是我跟你講
我不在乎第三季的毛利效果
我在乎是今年的營收增加
是
這是中這個更殘期
我看是殘期的利多
殘期利多
因為短期的利多出境而拉回
要買
這是殘期利多
因為營收連增40%
我預測成功了
不論對我做者的一切一切
預告前面去想想看
你要找分析師
歡迎來一次洽詢
08006-8085
或叫我來失去我
分貝1999
我們複製的環球金190%
國際約100%
哪有那個聯發科
怎麼樣100%以上報酬
南電100%報酬
金產100%
翻倍再翻倍
哇三個翻倍
以後就可以100萬
賺到1000萬
賺到800萬以上
好100萬
再上800萬
再上1000萬
1000萬賺到1億
翻倍190專案
我讓你抓住
我們來一起努力抓住
翻倍下一檔
翻倍股
預祝各位能夠賺大錢
台灣股市
我看到台積電法說
我不去預測
明天預測
明天真的難預測
不好意思
可是我可以告訴你
我願意肯定
今年5萬年以上見
不論對我錯
則則一切一切
以後要在前面
翻倍190專案
隨時結束
謝貴
我愛你們
拜拜
本公司与所推介分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家